[Applause]
whether they've got style yeah that's
the type of strike
[Applause]
that's it panel own NPI taking still
hear me
[Applause]
okay great sorry it's difficult to hear
over the clamor obviously they're now
using
nuggets trolleys to try and block the
police in it's calmed down a bit
I think they'll they'll have to send
reinforcements back to come and get
these guys out
this is always a very very dangerous
situation because those officers are
going to be scared and when they're
scared all guns blazing I suspect they
won't put up this long there are huge
numbers of people here though pray
that's something they'll have to build
into their thinking not just
demonstrators but large numbers of
ordinary travelers who are in the
airport hoping that it's going to reopen
clear its operation with civilians
inside like that would be really
difficult operation to achieve it was
almost same thing they have to find a
way to get them out
they're getting a right hammering on
this in this truck now
and let's say the road is pretty much
blocked